let's go to the phones for the first
time in 2020 at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty see what's
on people's minds let's go first to our
caller from the six one five area code
caller from six one five what's your
name where are you calling from what's
on your mind today
no I was doing what he did last night
what's the worst likely scenario like
I'll be expecting anything like to come
from this Austin your connection is the
worst of 20/20 so far I mean of course
this is only the first phone call but
listen I I gather that you're asking
about what's the worst-case scenario
based on Trump's unauthorized and
possibly illegal assassination of the
Iranian leader is that right yeah that's
that's right I'm sorry about the
connection that's okay listen the worst
case scenario is we get into the most
disastrous war of my lifetime which as I
said earlier in the show that says a lot
given that we've had Iraq and we've had
Afghanistan and it may all be because
Donald Trump thinks it may help him get
elected in 2020 and you know I don't
know if you've seen some of the tweets
that Donald Trump sent years ago about
Barack Obama and Iran saying Obama's
going to bomb Iran to try to get
reelected and you know it's unbelievable
that this is where we are but the
worst-case scenario is really bad oh
it's it's incredible and you know the
the saddest part about it is it often
works you know I mean when you look at
george w bush's reelection in 2004 it
came down to i think it was about a
hundred and forty thousand votes in Ohio
if I recall correctly and a lot of his
campaign was based on you don't want to
change horses midstream we're in the
middle of this Iraq thing and when
you're talking about you know Trump
likely losing the popular vote again in
2020 but being able to eke out a win
electoral II something like a contingent
of people who think we're in the middle
of this thing let's let him
finish it out it could actually win the
election forum that's the sickest part
of it yeah yeah well thanks for
answering my question all right I
appreciate it hope to hear from you
again looks like your connection got
much better there towards the end of the
call which we love